i have to mention something which is i
am
i think about you every day since we've
come to largo
because largo as i've been explaining to
people watching our show largo
is like the comedy theater
in los angeles it's this magical spot
and
we all come here and perform
uh when and the crowds are great and
it's this lovely old theater i got my
start here in 85 in a little room
uh lisa kudrow and i were literally
right across that's where we met
in this small room back in 86 when i
first came to la
and but there are pictures up of
everybody who's performed here
your picture's everywhere here because
this was apparently your second home
yes i've seen you many times i think
this is where you met
your late wife michelle isn't that right
yes i i
did a show um and i talked about
uh it was a yeah it was it was a show um
and on stage i did a bit about um
uh how uh irish women are my kryptonite
and uh and after the show she she was
walking out with some
and she was like hey irish girl is nice
and i was like thank you went just like
stunned and then my friend was greg
barron was like go
talk to her you idiot like he told me to
go talk to her so then i
ran out on the street and my first words
to her were hey
because she was 50 feet away already and
then i was like
i don't i don't have any game or
anything i just you seem really cool
here's my phone number could we go get
dinner like i just was
no i'm not going to try to be smooth or
cool here i i'm
i am hapless with women so i just you
know and that's how we met
uh this is uh
i'm very happy that you have managed to
and
and you've uh worked with other people
pulled together
this six-part docu-series yeah i'll be
gone in the dark which is
such a great lovely tribute
to uh your late wife michelle mcnamara's
work
of of i mean her obsession with
uh with the golden state killer and her
determination
and you've put this all together and it
really is a remarkable testament to what
she was able to do
i mean so much of it on her own and with
some other people in the community
who it's such a tribute to people online
who who are determined to solve
something they're not professionally
trained
it really is a fantastic story it's
amazing the director liz garvez
who is such a genius um has put together
this narrative that i don't i didn't
know how she was going to do it from
you know taking taking a book that was
already expansive and expanding it out
even further
to go into the victims lives and the
survivors lives and how
resilient they were and then everything
that michelle went through
and did what michelle wanted to do which
was the
the the killer is the least important
part of this story he you know he's just
this
insect that's disrupting what should
have should be a thriving ecosystem and
then
for what damage he's able to do the
ecosystem ends up thriving even more
and so the fact that she's able to show
all of that
to me is just amazing but it's also it's
for me some of them are a little i've
only there are six episodes
i've only been able to watch four i
don't think i'll be able to watch
five and six you know i had to watch all
the rough cuts and after episode four
which was this past sunday
i had to call liz and go i don't think i
can watch any more of these and i hope
you don't think that i'm being
she goes no no i absolutely understand
how amazed you got this far so
um and by the way her memorial service
took place in the largo i i was here
yeah i remembered uh
the memorial uh to to michelle was here
at the largo
and it was really lovely and uh everyone
turned out
and um i'm thinking of i just thought of
it today and i've thought about it often
when i see michelle in the footage for
the documentary
i remember this time when uh
completely by accident i think all of us
were in hawaii
at the same time and and
uh we saw it we ran into each other
and you were with michelle i'm with my
wife liza and we decided let's all get
dinner and we had this
lovely dinner and then i started
remember all of us talking to michelle
about
this obsession she had with finding this
killer
and i'm you know it was right in my
wheelhouse
so yeah i remember that spectacular
evening very fondly
you know that that would happen a lot we
would go to dinner with another couple
and
we would start off just kind of all
talking about whatever and then once if
once it got out what michelle does when
she was working on the whole dinner just
became so
but how do you try you use yeah quest
that is and she's like well yeah
it was always i remember there was a
time i was developing
a sitcom for myself with phil rosenthal
and there was a really telling moment
when he was like
i wanted it to be very very real life
like you know what my life was he goes
what does your wife do and i
explained to him what michelle did and
he said
okay well that's a way more interesting
show than what we're writing
so in this show your wife's gonna be a
party planner because
if your wife if your wife in this show
does what michelle does no one's going
to want
like why are we focusing on this idiot
doing i want to focus on her i was like
yeah that's probably a good idea so it
was that kind of thing